fines lucha vinci can't finished with
sole secures flowery yet to score in
this game he's out there with Leonard
green siakam and Gasol
Gasol lazy
[Music]
[Applause]
don't see you've been in a lot of these
spots what is the key to execution down
the stretch of the tight plow well I
think you want to give
clean shots as you can get if it Serrano
you want the bar to go to Kauai you want
to get on the free-throw line continue
to get stops like that a couple of four
shots from Booch of Incheon no buckets
[Applause]
ciacco likes the matchup on fournier
tennis shoot back to see after mommy and
tap can't finish
[Music]
now about them going to see ah come down
the stretch right here with the walk
letters
how does a good job nobody has a scored
a basket but he does a good job with
facilitating and making sure the ball
gets where it needs to be raptors bet
confront by 224 Big Shot right there and
it all came from double teaming the post
because Carlisle was overmatched swing
swing
big time shot in the corner by Duncan 11
lead changes 10 ties and it's a
three-point Orlando lead read one of the
best chase down artists in the game but
not that time Leonard
one of weeks
right dear
nineteen
[Applause]
what a game won in Toronto
diving inside
taking short
Leonard would swagger in his game
trying to untie it
[Applause]
what a shot by Kawhi Leonard right dear
one of the pick-and-roll
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
nice two-point basket
[Applause]
to make me wanna
Chauncey's sometimes it's just about a
great player making a great play and
that's exactly what it was I mean
isolation you want to best player to
have the ball in his hands and you can
live with the results I like much sense
with the wild level six times this
quarter seven lead changes this quarter
the latest courtesy of Kawhi Leonard who
has scored five straight for Toronto to
give them a two-point lead with 102 to
go in Game one
Gordon evil Germans Fournier Augustine
and Ross the five for Orlando here is
Fournier Ross :
taking missed it badly Gordon the
offensive rebound and a foul against
Toronto
they failed again this does of Orlando
at the current moment folks Clifford is
really good coming out the time mouth
drawing the place but pin downs for
shooters or maybe even watch a slip
right here
Augustine pick-and-roll with hooch of x7
is she
Augustine with the chatbox fading
Augustine
they Augustine is mr. reliable
every time they need something that
happened he's answered the bill to throw
one opportunity for Toronto you know
Leonard wants it later
gives it up Gasol
rebound magic and they can essentially
wine this down and try and hold for one
about a two second differential they can
get very close
[Applause]
leads five-three how about the smart
move getting the mismatch down the
switch right there and just raising up
for the [ __ ]